Thomas Malthus,
a famous 18th century
economist, famously wrote that most of
human history there was no growth.
In fact there could not be any growth.
Because as soon as you started to make
more food, what would happen?
Your children would survive. You'd have more sex.
Have more children. As we all do when we
eat too much. It was the 18th century,
things change. Then suddenly gobble
up all the excess food. So that's
what this graph is. This graph of world GDP
per capita. This is the graph
over here. It's not world GDP, which is a
measure of all the economic activity, but
the world GDP per person. Now I know that,
if you're anything like my history students
at Cornell, you hate math. But a little
math goes a long way. So how
manyof you are frightened of math
Well, San Francisco is a different crowd.
Y'all are like... okay, math, it's on! All right.
So if you look at this graph... I want you
to look at the year 0, or 1, or whatever
$467. Now, four hundred sixty-seven
dollars per person in the whole planet, now,
do you think that's totally accurate?
No, probably not, but it gives you a rough--
woah! Don't be touching my beer.
Okay, this is a rough sense...
Go to 1000 AD: $450. Roughly flat.
If you extend this graph back thousands and
thousands of years, roughly it would have
stayed flat. That's basically
the amount of human activity per person since
the dawn of Agriculture and then
something changes. Something changes to
make Malthus incorrect. And like
most historians he imagines the future
through the past. So Malthus is looking
back. And if that had been the case,
if nothing had changed Malthus would
had been correct. Before capitalism,
for the 99.7%
of all human history there was very
little investment there was very
little technological change the world of 01450
looked more or less like a world of
the year 0. These printers and glass blowers
looked like technologies that would have
been legible to the ancient Romans.
And in fact the largest enterprises
in Europe in this period had 40 people.
That's the scale of human endeavor
in the moment before capitalism really
emerges. And then suddenly things change.
Things change. And you get to this graph.
This very smooth looking graph.
Now I notice some of you are nodding your head.
What do you notice, class, about the
math of this graph? I want you to notice
the very smooth flat plane until roughly
the end. Now, it looks very flat because
the end, the period post 01800, is
so vertical it's very easy to draw this
graph. Even a robot can do it.
And it would be easy to forget that behind
this graph are people and events and
choices that made this growth possible. That
in fact this kind of growth wasn't
possible at any other period in the hundreds of
thousands of years that humans have existed.
you